p bonjour bienvenue sur diagonale tv
spéciale leçon pour débutants et bien
nous allons pour découvrir le monde
merveilleux du jeu d'échecs est bien
accueillie en nino maisuradze et bonjour
nino alors ni notions va rappeler quand
même que tu es tu es m féminin maître
international féminin échec donc tu nous
viennent de géorgie et tu viennes être
naturalisée française
donc tu vas tu vas faire partie
peut-être de l'équipe de france oui
petite précision il espère qu'on
naturalise et me laisserai donc voilà
dans quelques mois je crois oui
donc voilà j'ai fait partie des
fédérations françaises déjà j'ai même
changé la fédération donc voilà
peut-être mais où voir dominique
français voilà peut-être alors en
attendant tu va nous accompagner sur des
gones al tv spéciale leçon
pour débutants mais on va découvrir le
jeu d'échecs alors on va parler d'abord
de de l'historique du jeu en fait donc
c'est un vieux jeu tu t'y connais un peu
sur l'histoire mon pain oui bien sûr m
il faut dire et il ya beaucoup de
l'hygiène sur jeu d'échec très
entièrement et surtout il faut comme on
en ouvre à félix et je viens de landes
même s'il ya plusieurs hypothèses où ça
peut venir également de perth
oui mais au moins quand j'étais petit
ci-après comme ça qui s'était inventé
dans land il y as roi qui a commandé le
royal rocky s'ennuyer en fait il voulait
qu'on le croyait le divertissent alors
il ya la fameuse légende de 6 à lesage
qui aurait appris le roi enfin donc le
jeu le jeu d'échecs aux endroits à son
roi et qui pour le remercier lui a dit
me demande moi ce que tu veux il a dit
je mets je voudrais simplement quelque
chose très simple un grain de riz sur la
première fois la vidéo sur la deuxième
jusqu'à la 64e le royaume aussi c'est
que ça c'est qui est drôle oui l'unrwa
qui n'a pas compris qu est-ce que
c'était injuste il a dit c'est trop
facile et oui et puis en fait au final
au grand nombre de grains de riz si on
les ajoute ça fait plus que le nombre de
grains de riz actuellement produits dans
le monde donc ça fait quand même
beaucoup qui fait vraiment courir la
terre on peut dire aussi le jeu d'échecs
est un jeu très très puissant puisqu'il
ya plus de parties d'échecs possible que
d'atomes dans l'univers visible ce qui
ferait beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup alors
on va rappeler l'histoire donc 5ème
siècle en inde
ensuite sans doute passé dans le monde
arabe via la perse
d'où l'expression d'ailleurs échec et
mat puisque ça vient de chamakh oui qui
veut dire le roi est mort un géorgien
s'est toujours chamakh terre c'est à huy
en géorgien aussi voilà donc le roi est
mort le donc c'est le but du jeu d'échec
c'est de mettre le roi à mort puis
ensuite s'est passé en europe via
l'espagne alors de la conquête arabe
de l'espagne et puis à partir de
l'espagne après en europe puis dans le
monde entier
ça aussi donc ça aussi percer à lorient
via la chine et le japon et les échecs
japonais qu'on peut diverger mais
aujourd'hui le jeu mondialement connue
c'est celui qui est passé par l'europe
le jeu d'échecs mais c'est à transformer
ces il faut dire de dans le temps au
début je croyais même quatre joueurs au
début qui jouait aux échecs il y avait
les pièces oui les qu'audrey au départ
s'appelait le chanteur engagé dans le
jeu des quatre armes et un autre à la
carte
et puis donc c'est un jeu qui dont les
règles ont évolué au fil du temps même
encore récemment il ya des règles ont
changé par rapport notamment au contrôle
de temps qu'on donne aux joueurs ce
genre de choses donc c'est un jeu qui
dont les règles ont été perfectionnées
au cours des siècles donc vous imaginez
la perfection que peuvent avoir atteint
atteinte sert également à noter aussi
dans le parcours du jeu d'échecs comme
ça donc de l'aisne au cinquième siècle
via le monde arabe puis l'espagne et
c'est que les plus grands joueurs du
monde dont on a des traités très ancien
il ya des traités du 12ème siècle au nom
des 13 et même peut-être même avant très
anciens avaient des problèmes d'échec
les meilleurs joueurs du monde ont suivi
en général les nations qui dominait le
monde culturel ou scientifique ou
économique
donc les arabes en premier ensuite
l'espagne lors de la conquête de
l'amérique du sud est et l'or qui arrive
et en europe
ensuite il ya eu l'italie à la
renaissance la france lors de la
révolution française avec philidor le
fameux café la régence puis ensuite les
anglais avaient stone town est ensuite
les américains aussi avec murphy au
moment de l'indépendance à des amériques
fin des états unis il ya eu ensuite les
autrichiens et allemands les steinitz
tarrach au début du fin 19e le jeune
fille en huitième avant les fameuses
guerre mondiale etc et ensuite il ya eu
évidemment les russes et les américains
lors de la guerre froide et qui ont
culminé avec le match fischer se passe
qui est aujourd'hui en 2008
et bien c'est un indien qui est champion
du monde donc ses revenus aux origines
c'est vishy anand qui indiens et les
chinois aussi qui perce beaucoup
notamment chez les filles elles déjà eu
plusieurs champions du monde féminine
chez les filles mais aussi chez les
hommes je crois que la chine a fini
troisième
l'avant dernière olympiade donc d'échec
la compétition internationaux qui
démontre que le jeu d'échecs rebasculer
en orient notamment avec la percée de la
chine et de l'inde au niveau au niveau
économique mondiale alors ça c'est pour
l'histoire du jeu de chaise maintenant
on va revenir au jeu lui-même qui nous
intéresse aujourd'hui déjà oui j'ai
quand même préciser donc c'est le jour
qui rassemble beaucoup aux batailles
il faut dire le combat bien sûr c'est
pour ça toujours est il ya le grand
général etc
les personnes mêmes militaires ou
stratégiquement impliqué dans les
politiques comme napoléon d'ailleurs
aussi qu'ils aiment beaucoup les échecs
c'est vrai dans quelques parties n'a pas
les mêmes histoires qui nous regarde
quelqu'un partie napoléon et d'ailleurs
je ne sais pas pourquoi il ya les jeunes
qui circulent en géorgie et sur napoléon
ii mais qui n'est pas forcément comme
pour le français quelqu'un il était
emprisonné il y avait ses amis qui l'ont
noyé une position d'échec oui sert à
cacher une plan stratégique pour
échapper je n'ai pas ces gens pour les
fêtes et les contes et légendes en
géorgie c'est vraiment connu en russie
aussi cette histoire
après je sais pas non mais par contre il
n'a plus à pas ils ont dit non mais à
sainte-hélène notamment napoléon site
d'ailleurs dans le mémorial de
sainte-hélène qui l'a dicté à aux
personnes qui l'accompagnaient lors de
cet exil son dernier exil il expliqué
clairement qui faisait des parties
d'échecs oui c'était vraiment un féru de
jeux d'échecs donc jeu de stratégie par
excellence alors maintenant on va parler
du jeu lui-même à l'ombre on va parler
de l'échiquier il y avoir 64 cases déjà
commencé et il ya donc aux vivaces juste
je vais demander à la régie de nous
mettre l'échiquier voilà sur l'écran
sans voilà ici on a un échiquier vide
donc on comme tu dis juste avant il ya
effectivement 64 cases alors comment on
peut les compter ses cases s'affairant
compte alors ses huit sur huit
donc ici on a un deux trois quatre cinq
six sept huit cases et vers le haut
on a 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 dont 8 x 8 64 cases
vous pouvez les compteurs la main tel
est pas trompée avec le damier qui peut
avoir plus de cas sachez que c'est
toujours 64 cas ça n'existait pas une
échelle plus large où avez-vous fait
titre voilà l'échiquier voilà exactement
l'échiquier ses 8 x 8 alors que le
damier c'est dix fois disent oui le
damier ça peut jouer sur vie choisir 8
aussi normalement plus classe et que je
leur dise alors que les échecs et voilà
c'est chic et ça voilà alors pour passer
de chiqué alors comment maintenant on a
on a noté donc on a noté cet échiquier
alors je crois qu'il ya ni noah une
façon de le
de le repérer les cases je crois que
c'est important
oui bien sûr vous voyez sur l'échiquier
donc il y à lourdes alphabétique avec
abc des péages et aussi numérotée à
gauche donc ça ici en verre se sont
abaissées d e f g h
ce qu'on appelle les je crois qu'on peut
lire les colonnes voilà donc ça c'est ça
par exemple celle que je marque en verre
à gauche ici celle ci qu'on appelle ça
la colonne ah oui et là c'est le ranger
en bas et ça cela arrange et numéro un
mais c'est pas jusqu en bosse donc
disons que horizontalement sait on les
appelle les ranger alors que
verticalement on s'appelle les colons
voilà donc ici colonnes à willie colon
nommé au lycée jusqu'à par exemple quand
le rapport aux destinées de quoi on
parle voilà hélas et les ranger donc on
les appelle effectivement on les numéros
dont deux par des chiffres 1 2 3 4 5 6
là vous voyez que c'est un peu comme
n'importe quel plat nous carte de la
ville où il ya même région sont définis
par juste par exemple et 4 as fait ton
ventre et donc par exemple à 4-4
effectivement donc abcde ici 1,2 alors
un deux trois quatre
voilà cette quasi si cette case ici
c'est la case 4e garrocher de voilà je
peux le montrer en jaune ici c'est la
casa on réunir son deuxième plus tard
des toits sont donc à noter également il
faut pas se tromper c'est qu'ils
arrivent souvent le
aude évident de ne pas me très chic et
pas correctement parce que remarqué si
vous tournez l'échiquier
ça peut être donner n'importe quoi il
faut toujours que la casse clair soit à
droite en bas
voilà donc ici on deviner que vous avez
tchéquie correctement placé voilà donc
ça c'est important
par convention par convention on met
toujours la case blanche à droite parce
que si on inverse
enfin c'est toujours correct sera
toujours 64 cases et tout mais c'est la
convention c'est qu'on met la case
blanche à droite parce qu'après on plus
tard les règles de rock tout ça mais
après ça marche plus et on inverse
donc si votre ticket numéroté retenir
qu'un alphabet ça doit être en bas pour
que ce soit lisible déjà mais si votre
chez game n'est pas numérotées il n'y a
pas de notation là dessus dans ces cas
où était le cash les loquace droite en
bas ça doit être blanc voilà d'ailleurs
à pas confondre avec le damier aussi ou
celle inverse c'est la case noire qui à
droite donc le damier ça rien à voir
donc confondez pas le dernier 10 x 10
cases noires à droite avec l'échiquier
qui lui c'est le jeu d'échec c'est pas
le même jeu c'est 8 x 8 et donc à ce
blanche à droite et donc on a parlé
effectivement des colonnes vers le haut
comme ça a b c d e f g h et les ranger 1
2 3 4 6 et donc maintenant ou rappelle
qu'elle a parlé colonna est rangé il
existe les diagonales les diagonales
on repère les diagonales alors par
exemple ici suscite une diagonale
oui alors comment comme on distingue
cette cette chose là c'est les
diagonales dans son repaire ici
l'indifférence par contre par abord qu
lone ranger que l'on appelle les vicas
donc jusqu'à vous alors que les
diagonales peut exister les diagonales
longue diagonale qui ont grandi roulant
comme on appelle habits cazaux ça peut
être aussi à ghlin a juste au cas par
exemple des têtes on peut montrer de la
ducasse cas ce que ça paie donne alors
une diagonale à deux cases par exemple
c'est
alors donc celle ci par exemple ici on
va le montrer en jaune ici voilà ça
c'est une petite diagonale fait juste le
diagonal voyait ses petites diagonales
c'est la diagonale à 7 b 8
vous pouvez rester sur la très chic et à
7 des 8 à part qu'on prendrait cette
diagonale là qu'on appelle h 1 à 8
mais certains ont appelé la grande
diagonale la grande diagonale parce
qu'effectivement ça c'est bon là il ya
deux grandes diagonales et à celle là
évidemment sur cases blanches ici est
celle ci sur cases noires à part ça donc
à savoir quel os il y allait d'un mail a
eu droit en expliquant sa défense alors
on va enlever un peut-être un peu les
cas effectivement donc il faut juste
avoir le temps de le faire parce que il
ya beaucoup de choses qui sont marqués
pour vous faciliter donc la vision
donc vous avez bien retenu les
diagonales et ranger les colonnes donc
on va repérer ici ça ça va être la dame
tout ce côté là en pénétrant de m
voilà on va séparer on va simplement
mettre toutes les cases graal alors
essayons donc en fait toute la moitié de
gauche de l'échiquier on appellera
sallèles dames et c'est pareil ici vous
allez voir pourquoi parce qu'on va vous
apprendre les places en débit est hélas
est scellée loin
d'ailleurs on voit bien qu'il ya les
rois qui sont placés à pourquoi on a mis
le roi parce que vos échecs il peut pas
y avoir de position sans endroit ça
n'existe pas donc il faut au moins les
deux rois pour que la position soit
légale tant koala en jaune c'est les
rois et donc envers par conséquence les
dents voilà donc pourquoi on a fait le
tour du tableau du plateau passons
maintenant je crois qu'on a tous vu les
colonnes les ranger les diagonales
on a vu les petits diagonale et grandes
diagonales maintenant viennent sépare
effectivement l'aileron allèles dames on
a bien expliqué que l'échiquier avait
une case blanche à droite on a bien tout
résumé et maintenant on va vous montrer
l'échiquier tel qu'il est au début de la
partie
la pression'' départ travailler tout de
suite ça s'est rempli donc voilà toutes
les pièces telles qu'elles sont en géo
diplomatique qui font l'objet de cette
de cette leçon s'assied à savoir chaque
adversaire est là
sps alors cette pièce donc on voit ici
il ya ici à 8 pions voix 8 pions les
pieds c'est range donc sur première et
deuxième rangée et sur 7e ou 8e c'est
toujours ça il n'y a pas d'autre
possibilité
au début ces armes alors les pions sont
toujours sur la deuxième rangée pour les
blancs sur la septième rangée pour les
noirs selon là où vous expliquer déjà
donc des nominations donc il y a le roi
alors le roi une pièce plus important
quand vous déjà défini ses parts à voir
un homme voilà ça c'est le roi si on
voit le roi blanc et jaune en france et
le roi bien sûr parce que ça n'existait
pas avoir deux ou trois ans suit ensuite
il ya les temps donc chacun à sa dame et
pour mieux comprendre à imaginer c'est
leur droit et donc la reine mais juste
aux échecs on le donnait la dame qui est
pratiquement associe avec la reine
donc on ne marque pas le ring en août
parce que on va pas se tromper avec
après vous allez voir on ne marque par
rapport aux initiales le roi ce sera r
alors que si on appelle la dame renzaho
de lozère bien sûr donc ce sera donc
leur os et les dents mais c'est ça en
fait le voilà donc on a vu le roi
la dame alors elles sont toujours placés
au même endroit donc ici juste à centre
juste à côté
donc après il ya les fous et chaque
année deux fous de fou pour les blancs
d'oeuf ou pour les noirs donc les fous
sont à côté du couple royal
oui c'est un peu comme les conseillères
de bons pour se rappeler où le fou du
roi tout simplement l'amuseur public à
celui qui a amusé le monarque
on voit les toujours à côté du roi oui à
près d'un an par rapport aux différents
paye sa définition autrement il est
certain qu'ils préfèrent appelle les
éléphants
je ne sais pas quoi et alors on peut le
dire ça effectivement suivant les pays
s'appelle pas parler autant le roi et la
dame sont toujours aux même façon alors
en arabe le fictivement je crois que
c'est l'éléphant et on a dû faire une
représentation de chez qui il sait trop
quelle votre échec et que vous avez chez
vous il se trouve que vous aurez payé
senti vos différentes mais à comprendre
des façons
à partir du moment où vous savez comment
les déplacés et les lire ne vous appelez
plus ou moins qu'on voulait mais nous on
vous dont les non officiels
voilà après ça soit rien n'émerge pas qu
en anglais c'est l'évêque c'est pas le
fou c'est l'évêque qui changent et c'est
l'évêque donc c'est ouais c'est ça
dépend des pays après évidemment de
koster en typo comme le conseiller du
roi et d'hambourg voilà les familles
royales
alors ensuite il nous reste ces pièces
là donc les canonniers donc ça c'est les
cavaliers est pratiquement toujours
représenté par la tête de cheval voilà
donc après les fous donc les cavaliers
donc là c'est facile on cavaliers donc
c'est un peu comme le chef d'armée os x
terra qui protège le roi donc les
chevaliers bon alors évidemment assez
représentée par un cheval ça s'appelle
cavaliers ont dit plus tôt on peut dire
qu'on peut dire cheval aussi oui les
amateurs ont l'habitude de dire chez
valve je vais là où l'autre l'un ou
l'autre indifféremment mais plutôt
cavaliers dans l'anneau station la
notation claasen les livres et ses
terrasses escaliers
voilà et enfin les taux les tours donc
là les tours on voit bien les tours du
château fort donc ils sont aux
extrémités ici complet mais voilà voilà
les tours et donc qu'il ya après les
pions qu'on soit on compare avec les
soldats qui sont placés bien sûr devant
la au problème donc les pions des roms
les fantassins qui sont placés devant
l'armée prêts à attaquer au moindre
signe au moindre signe guerrier donc
prêt à se lancer dans la bataille et qui
sont les plus nombreux donc il s'est
sacrifié le plus facilement comme dans
la vraie vie on sacrifie plus âgés les
gréements que les pièces donc pour élire
le facilement on récapitule tout
simplement qu'est donc il y a le roi
avec entre guillemets sa famille qui
s'appelle adam a entouré avec les
conseillères et après par le chiffre d'
armer les cavaliers et bien sûr vers la
france contre les forces entre
guillemets les tours qui protège et
défend les soldats voilà alors on va
juste rappeler donc effectivement le
couple royal donc et au centre comme
vous voyez royaume bien au centre alors
juste pour distinguer comment placer les
pièces regarder ainsi totalement
symétrique est en fait la dame elle est
sur sa couleur
la case noire et la dame blanche sur la
case blanche oui donc à noter donc c'est
ça et après le roi sur la case juste à
côté n'est 37 pas qu'une façon assez
voilà alors par exemple si vous vous
trompez sur l'échiquier si vous mettez
la case noire à droite et que vous dites
que la dame sur sa couleur vous allez
inverser la position du roi et la dame
c'est pour ça qu'il faut garder toujours
là la case à droite par convention
évidemment pour ne pas pour ne pas se
tromper on rappelle également que c'est
toujours les blancs qui commence qui est
aussi erreurs habituelles de ce début
donc et qui savent pas qu'ils ont
parfois de commencer avec les noirs oui
non c'est la règle c'est les blancs qui
commence aux échecs toujours le repas il
ressort qu'il a commencé voilà alors
maintenant qu'on a vu évidemment dans
cette leçon on regardera pas le
déplacement des pièces qui feront
l'objet de leçons ultérieure mais par
contre
on va parler de l'éthique je crois oui
un petit pot pour rappeler les ticos et
j'ai donc qu'il est sûre si vous jouez
entre les amis vous comporter plus ou
moins qu'on voulait mais si vous avez à
nu des impôts respectait les éthiques
reconnu 18 internationalement c'est un
déjà serré la main de vos adversaires
avant commencé la partie et après aussi
ça se fait toujours et à la fin aussi
donc
au début on sert le mans c'est pas
important qui va tendre la mort première
c'est par rapport qui arrive première
peut-être par contre à la fin c'est le
perdant qui doit donc d'un blâme ans oui
bonjour si vous faites passer très
impoli ce sera mal vu donc anti poux ça
donc on préviennent également que aux
échecs il faut pas parler comme vous et
ça c'est bien sûr n'applique pas si vous
voulez entre les amis mais dans le
tournoi par exemple on n'a pas droit
parlait en or sauf pour dire échec
oui ça aussi bon on peut pas trop en
dessous bon karaboué qu'est ce que ça
veut dire après il ya aussi à savoir
oser au tournoi si vous touchez une
pièce il faut la jouer
vous n'avez pas droit de toucher une
piste d'après jeu une autre pièce une
fois pièce touché on les déplace et
aussi il ya plusieurs règles comme ça
donc par rapport que ça va se distinguer
si vous jouez chez vous en 3 min ou à un
haut niveau pour moi donc si vous
touchez également par exemple qui est
adverse d'adversaires normalement si
vous pouvez la prendre vous n'avez plus
droit de ne pas prendre mais voilà donc
si on touche une pièce alors si ces
pièces à nous il faut la jouer
oui pas si on touche une pièce adverse
et qu'il faut la prendre c'est prenable
ils veulent apprendre s'il faut la
prendre si la règle nous impose devient
une autre course et il y à une pièce qui
n'est pas bien centré sur une case et
vous avez un but de le corriger
il faut déclarer votre attention en
avance bien sûr droit de toucher les
pistes mais dans ce cas où dit non j'ai
c'est pas pour jouer mais c'est juste
donc le fondeur ja double oui jade ou
alors ça c'est un mot de vue français au
lycée île mythique qui s'emploie au
niveau international oui ils font ça
fonctionne là où on voit que je vous
dise général jaloux
c'est là qu'on voit que le jeu est passé
ça veut dire que vous dansez mon malheur
vous touchez ps et vous n'êtes pas
obligé jouer cette pièce est à savoir
aussi une fois vous déplacer une ps si
vous avez lâché la main le coup est déjà
fait voilà donc quand on lâche une pièce
coup joué donc ça serait la réponse est
qu en général
par contre si vous permet encore lâché
l'amant vous avez droit de reprendre ces
coûts mais vous serez obligé de jouer
cette pièce là voilà cirque si vous
n'avez pas encore lâché la pièce vous
pouvez toujours la remettre à sa
position initiale vous devez la jouer
puisque vous l'avez touché mais vous
pouvez changer le coup tant que vous
l'avez pas lâcher tant que vous n'avez
pas lâcher effectivement votre pièce sur
une case donne alors je vais peut-être
raconter une anecdote quand même là
dessus je veux pas si le situe la
connaît mais kasparov lui même avait
lâché une pièce je crois qu'il avait
lâché une pièce vassa judit polgar weeds
aoc ou africaines fawe à dire dans les
accès dans les arrêts système et ça fait
toute une histoire puisque judit polgar
avait dit messi mais s'il a lâché la
pièce qu'ils font maintenant je n'ai pas
lâché et finalement l' arbitre a donné
raison kasparov kasparov a pu reprendre
son coup et jouer ça là même qui a subi
non puisqu'il l'avait touché sur une
autre case sauf qu'à la vidéo
dans la vidéo on voit qu'il avait
effectivement lâché la pièce dont qu'il
avait triché kasparov même me voyez même
les plus grands joueurs peuvent arriver
à tricher mais ça a été reconnue comme
une triche et regardez même aujourd'hui
on en parle donc ça veut dire quand même
que c'est quand ça arrive c'est pas très
bien vu c'est pas très bien vu surtout
en plus si vous jouez face à une dame
alors il faut être encore plus galants
faut être encore plus correct que bon
encore que si vous êtes face à un homme
de risquer de prendre une baffe
vous prenez vos risques mais l'érection
assez stricte quand vous voyez justin
corto petite différence d'ailleurs en
ajoutons dans les tournois vous pouvez
aussi voir la pendule n'hésiterai pas
qu'est ce qu'on sait sur quoi on clique
c'est pas forcément politique mais on
nous explique à la maison souvent de
jouer son pendule
oui et si nous il existe aussi le point
de vue voilà tournoi dans les tournois
mais même à la maison sur une joue
beaucoup de gens s'intéressent qu'à ce
que celle attendue
si on veut jouer aux échecs rapidement
parce que sinon ça peut durer des jours
évidemment c'est pas le but
en général on a une double pendule et on
peut en parler très rapidement si c'est
simplement donc on a par exemple dix
minutes par joueur pour jouer toute la
partie donc c'est un capital temps il ya
une double pendule donc cancer vous de
jouer
c'est votre temps qui diminue vous avez
votre propre pendule qui diminue quand
vous avez joué vous appuyez sur la
pendule
votre pendule s'arrête votre capital
temps est préservée par contre c'est le
capital tant de l'adversaire qui
diminuée si vous passez en dessous de
zéro eh bien vous avez perdu la partie
donc il faut absolument jouer rapidement
de façon à ce que le temps ne soit pas
un critère de fin de partie ce qui peut
arriver mais qui est dommage
elle vaut mieux terminer la partie sur
l'échiquier voilà donc on a fait le tour
des vraiment de la présentation générale
sur 7 sur 7 le son du jeu d'échecs un
historique on a vu donc l'échiquier avec
le positionnement des pièces essayent
d'arrêter les normes des pièces essayer
de retenir les toits les noms des pièces
revoyez bien la vidéo avec les tour les
cavaliers les foulées pions la dame est
le roi la position du chic et les
colonnes les ranger les diagonales et on
a à peu près tout vu
c'est bien d'apprendre historique aussi
du jeu et puis les tic très important
tout ce que vous expliquez nino pour
toucher une pièce si vous touchez une
pièce vous devez la jouer si vous l'avez
lâcher ses jouets et les règles de série
la même adversaire au début à la fin de
la partie
voilà vous avez les bases pour rentrer
dans le monde merveilleux du jeu
d'échecs et aller plus avant dans la
connaissance de ce jeu voilà je crois
que c'est fini pour cette première
émission où iront passer par un
déplacement des clients on verra sa
seconde saison
voilà sur une autre émission que vous
invitons à découvrir sur diagonale tv le
son est spécial débutant vous remercie
d'avoir suivi cette émission mémoriser
tout cela avant de passer à la suite
merci minino avoir horreur